[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts oh
just finished two bears sorry Bert we
miss you we love you we hope you're back
soon thanks for doing it buddy hey
hey
you got here you checked out the new
studio it's awesome thank you very cool
I haven't armed rest of anybody in like
a [ __ ] decade if I was just competing
with you and Ari I'd be like you know
we'll just have some fun yeah but with
bird I'm like I want you to die
you talk so much [ __ ] I'm like I'm gonna
take you to the depths of hell did we do
sober for the month right which is two
birds benefits if he wasn't such a drunk
he'd probably be an amazing athlete
it's great to know where the dumbest
person in the audience is thanks
thanks for sitting up front
today's Wednesday September 28th and we
have a packed episode of the drug World
comedy update this week with Joe Rogan
visiting your mom's house Studios a new
Gillian Keith special dropping in just
six days and Andrew Schultz once again
breaking the internet we're getting into
all that and more in this video but real
quick if this is your first time
watching the joke World comedy news
usually these come out every Monday and
we're in a different Studio it looks a
little more professional but right now
I'm in a hotel we were evacuated for
Hurricane Ian so
if I don't die then this will be back to
normal on Monday so make sure you
subscribe like and download this episode
on Spotify to support the show and if I
do end up passing away in this hurricane
you can unlike you can undownload and
you can unsubscribe I don't really care
but for now let's just go business as
usual I'm sorry for the delay and the
lack of production but things will be
back on track Monday
hopefully
and maybe they won't be
but I don't think this looks that bad
honestly for a hotel room you always
[ __ ] on Connecticut the dumbest place in
the country it's not a real State it's a
highway between Boston and New York and
it's filled with people that have no
hope
holy [ __ ] they have no hope I've never
heard somebody go harder on Connecticut
so we had Joe Rogan sitting in for Bruce
Chrysler on two bears one cave this week
which is great because we have a
two-hour conversation between Joe Rogan
and Tom Segura two of my favorite
comedians two of the best comedians in
the game right now the video is uploaded
on Monday and Ari has well over a
million views it's nice to see Rogan
going on his Friends Podcast kind of
making the rounds as a guest he was
recently on this past weekend he was on
flagrant a few weeks ago so that's cool
to see Joe in a different setting
instead of being the host now he's a
guest a little bit more relaxed he also
arm wrestled any one of the ymh workers
which was a very good clip
that's crazy
[Music]
you ready
okay go
come on
come on
[Laughter]
that wasn't even a little difficult wait
say that again it wasn't even a little
difficult
I let him try for a while
also the fact that this arm wrestling
clip took place in this studio instead
of the two bear Studio makes me think
that maybe they could have recorded
back-to-back episodes one of two bears
one cave and one of your mom's house so
this could be huge for Joe Rogan's
career doing two bears one cave and your
mom's house on the same week it's nice
that Tom segor is putting his friends on
finally and supporting smaller comedians
chain
this is my new boyfriend Ryan
he's a doctor
he actually played Pro Hockey too God oh
God Gillian keeps a special premieres
Tuesday October 4th at 8pm Eastern and
according to their website
gillingkeeves.tv Gillian keeves the
special is a feature-length sketch
comedy special from John McKeever and
Shane Gillis this unique comedy film
includes original sketch comedy behind
the scenes footage outtakes as well as
live footage from Gillian keeves live at
the TLA in Philadelphia
look at this loser
no I'm just messing oh hey man yeah
right idiot
Shane
I still love you
wait what
[Music]
you can pre-order tickets right now on
their website gilliancieves.tv they're
ten dollars but you get access to the
special for a full year after your
purchase is that yours right right there
bro Latina okay
you gotta be careful with her you on
birth control
maybe maybe not now you need certified
yes from them okay
don't [ __ ] with that pull out method
with Latinas
Latin girl's stomach her belly button
just opens up and takes that [ __ ] in Doc
you gotta come on her back that's why
they call them wet backs now God
if you didn't pay for the new Andrews
old special last month you're in luck he
put on YouTube for free this week raking
in almost a million views a day since
he's done it that was three days ago
he's at 2.5 million right now and the
special is awesome it's so [ __ ] funny
it's a Schultz special it's great but
what I think is cooler than all of that
than the actual content of the comedy
itself is just the process that it's
been watching Infamous come out you know
they want us to make some cuts and we're
like listen you know I've had enough of
that what's the point what's the point
of being independent what's the point of
doing this [ __ ] what's the point of
creating your own stuff we're gonna
write to jokes we're gonna edit it we're
gonna put it all out and we have the
opportunity to do it we go in front of
audiences and do this all the [ __ ]
time we know what's funny and what isn't
we know where the [ __ ] line is you
know people like it you know it works
the the the the the [ __ ] audience is
the one that gives me the notes yes do
you know what I mean like I'm on stage
if the joke's bombing I know it's not
good yeah the joke is killing I know
it's good right and we're in front of
thousands of [ __ ] people literally
hundreds of thousands if you look over
the course of the tour like we know what
the people can take and what they can't
take and
I don't know like I just wanted to trust
that relationship I have with them we
all know the story of how he sold it to
a streamer then bought it back released
it on his own website taking a big risk
there and how it paid off plentiful he
said I think he made more than three
times his money at one point it's
probably grown since then and a lot of
people like to bring up yeah that's cool
but Louis CK has been doing this for
years Schultz didn't invent this Louie's
been putting his special on his website
behind a paywall many many years and
that is true but I think it's a little
different what Louis does and what
Schultz did for a few reasons number one
Schultz was never you know canceled in
the public eye like Louie was so he
still had all of his options he still
had all the streamers that he could have
gone to in fact he sold it to one
apparently was probably Amazon Prime but
that hasn't been confirmed but he sold
it and then bought it back to save the
jokes to save the Integrity of the
comedy in the special which sends a huge
message I think to the whole industry
one comedians hey you're allowed to do
this on your own we don't need these
other third-party streamers and to those
third-party streamers listen you better
start letting these comedians do
whatever they want have no notes or else
they're just going to do this on their
own and probably make more money than
they would with you we just did not want
to compromise material and
um they just did not want to compromise
it was like an entire businesses yeah I
mean there's multiple bits like multiple
even lines and other bits and like I get
that I understand I have empathy for
people who are in that business right
because they're not creating the content
right they're making sure that their
business is successful right so like I'm
not angry necessarily that they're
protecting themselves and to be fair
like the person that's at the streamer
was on my side but everybody got a boss
and then after all of that releasing on
YouTube for free and getting almost a
million views a day so far and still
early I mean that's just so badass the
production this is so great it's not
like a YouTube special production the
production in Infamous is next level for
any special for a Dave Chappelle Netflix
special this production puts that to
shame I mean if you know if you've
watched it you know exactly what I'm
talking about but I think Andrew Schultz
has done it again then change the comedy
game forever I'm sure he'll do it a few
more times in his career as things
evolve as technology evolved but this is
really cool for comedy if you look past
just the great special that it was
I it's exciting
[Applause]
guest spots from last week your mom's
house did not have a guess it was just
Tom and Christina P two bears one cave
was Joe Rogan and Tom Segura which we
already covered tigerbelly was still a
barely and whiskey Ginger talked to Nick
Swardson my buddy's brother went to
Colorado it's always about Colorado and
I think they legalized mushrooms they
did yeah they do criminalize it yeah
they decriminalized it
oh of course Colorado yeah because then
and you know it's just funny like now
I'm picturing people like working at a
funeral home like Hey we're looking for
a casket for my mother and then being
like
yeah
what color
what color I don't [ __ ] know man
Mikey's painting one right now
huge bro do you like um bees her Birds I
painted a lot of birds and bees on this
one hey this one we already used for
recycling it you know what I mean you
got
foreign
mushroom laughing is panic laughing kill
Tony this week was Josh Wolf and Mike
Feeney flagrant head on Brian Callan and
then their most recent episode was with
Mr Beast this past weekend talked to
Caleb Presley which is honestly one of
my favorite episodes of this whole week
those two together are great the
Honeydew talked to Chappelle Lacey Joe
Rogan had on David tell last week two
goats going at it right there and we
might be drunk head on Rick Glassman new
specials out right now we still have
Hernan hershberg jokes from the
underground out on YouTube and then Joe
Coy live from the LA forum is on Netflix
other than that not a lot of comedy
specials coming out within the last week
I guess if you count Gillian Kiev
special coming up next week six days
from now October 4th that could be a
third special to watch out for although
it's not to stand up it is a special
from a stand-up comedian that's it for
this week's comedy news update we'll be
back on Monday with some more common
news if I don't die in this hurricane
but if I do end up drowning I just want
to say figure out amongst yourselves
who's going to run joke World moving
forward and make sure you subscribe and
like and download and follow us on
Instagram do everything you can with Joe
world right now because if I do die
you're going to want to mourn me
publicly get a lot of sympathy from the
public oh this YouTuber I followed he's
dead
so that's just another reason to
subscribe I guess
okay hopefully I'll see you Monday
[Music]